[Music]
let that your heart
[Music]
[Applause]
and pretend you
so let love
you
sail the Moon
[Music]
with you
by your side
close your tires
[Music]
and soon
I'll see your smile
[Music]
in Her Dream Baby
don't worry
it's okay
I'll always be with you
[Music]
here your
heart
beat
[Music]
don't worry
it's okay
no one should have to suffer such loss
you know I meant that when I said I
understand how you feel I feel
I feel told laying down like an anchor
[Music]
hey
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
great to see you uh well Mr kojimo it's
been three years you're on this stage
with us in 2019 where you won best game
Direction uh DS2 has been announced uh
what can you tell us how is it going to
be different than DS1
[Music]
I can't really be specific right now but
you just seen the trailer and I put a
lot of things inside so I want you guys
to talk about it and find Details in it
good luck all right uh well I know we
have some of uh the cast from the game
with us here uh hello great to have you
guys with us here
um Troy is here as well we heard him
there hello Troy
um we're so excited about this
collaboration you have with an amazing
cast I wanted to ask you the story of
this game how is the pandemic and what
we've been through how has that impacted
your storytelling and the theme of this
game
history
well I had the story written before the
pandemic but after experiment
experiencing the pandemic I just rewrote
the whole thing uh the story from
scratch
foreign
I also didn't want to predict any more
future so I rewrote it
Mr Kojima it's
I wanted to ask generally what's next
for you as a Creator I know we have our
fun
podcasts
well yes I'm doing the DS2 right now and
also one other title that's completely
new I'm kind of experimenting at the
moment and also other visual projects
I'm still working on so I'll hope to
reveal it soon I said well you're always
very prolific and we love you for it
hideo Kojima everyone
[Applause]
well next we have another